[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est une chose que nous avons lancés
dans l'aisne voyez nous avions jusqu'ici
une chasse sur hirson une chasse aux en
plaine en forêt et nous avons voulu
lancer dans l'aisne une chasse aux
canards notamment ils devront trouver là
un prieta terriens qui s'est intéressé
cette formule
nous pouvons prendre ici à fourdrain
une vingtaine de chasseurs à la journée
avec un prix de journée bien sûr qu'elle
est terminée par le prix était
quel prix de la journée le prix de la
journée sera de 250 francs
[Applaudissements]
mon idée primaire est elle celle ci j'ai
pensé qu' il y avait des gens certain
nombre de personnes qui voulaient tirer
et qui n'avait pas de terrain pour
chasser
que je leur offrais la possibilité de
pouvoir venir quand il le désirait avec
le calendrier qu'on a établi avec des
chasses aux canards et des chats se
faisant de pouvoir passer une après midi
agréable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
halo reach est pas là oui ça ressemble
plus au ball-trap qu'à la chasse c'est
surtout je pense lui sur intéressant
point de vue tirs on peut pas comparer
ce à une chasse naturel bien sûr mais
enfin pour tous les gens s'ils voulaient
qu'ils aiment le tir qui aiment le tir à
un tir vivant si vous voulez je pense
que cette chose intéressante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son blindé
le style est bon car les oiseaux était
volée parfaitement bien il volé très
haut et ont provoqué des coups de fusil
magnifique d'ailleurs à une grande
hauteur et par conséquent c'est le but a
été atteint pour les chasseurs
[Musique]